you've heard the public health message
trans fats are bad for you they are the
Darth Vader of processed foods so what
are they
trans fats occur naturally in a few meat
and dairy products but they're an
ingredient most commonly found in foods
and snacks like chips baked goods and
fried foods otherwise called partially
hydrogenated oils on labels trans fats
are used by companies because they give
food a longer shelf-life enhance texture
and stay solid at room temperature oh
and they can also make food taste
delicious but trans fats can affect your
health the National Institutes of Health
say that trans fats are bad for your
heart and may pose a risk for certain
cancers they also increase your LDL bad
cholesterol and lower your HDL good
cholesterol now you know what is a food
stamp first thing is these days they're
not actually stamps but government debit
cards they're given to people with low
income